say mama i know i'm a cute boy
nicki minaj dishes on being a mom and
reveals how motherhood has changed her
yes absolutely
and i'll wear that title proudly too on
thursday the grammy winner answered fans
burning questions on twitter and when
one of her barbs asked how the arrival
of her nearly one-year-old son whom she
shares with her hubby kenneth petty has
changed her she sweetly said this quote
more patience and understanding with
everyone he makes me so happy
you a cute boy
and get this when another fan asked if
their little boy will be their only
child or if they plan to grow their
family nikki responded quote grow i mean
you talk about the family like how hard
are we practicing right now not to put
you on the spot
you practice we practice all the time
during her q a the 38 year old rapper
also revealed she will no longer be
performing at this year's mtv video
music awards explaining i just pulled
out i'll explain why another day she
went on sharing her appreciation for
those in charge of the show including
producer bruce gilmer before writing
quote next year we there baby mtv has
yet to comment on nikki's remarks as she
had not yet been confirmed or announced
as a performer i always want to be great
at anything i do but back to nicki and
her sweet baby boy well thank you it's
been a busy week for the new mom who
brought her son along for a double date
with rihanna and asap rocky on monday
that's the rapper and her man holding on
to their baby boy while asap and riri
cozy up on the couch next to the proud
parents caribbean things
and all that came shortly after nicki
shared the moment her little one
seemingly spoke his first word on camera
[Music]
nikki followed all that cuteness up by
posting some more home videos with her
son like this moment with the 11 month
old whose name has yet to be revealed
charging towards the camera
nikki welcomed her son in september 2020
and posted the first images of him in
january
along with a caption that read in part
quote becoming a mom is by far the most
fulfilling job i've ever taken on
sending love to all the superhero
mothers out there
[Music]
you